hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Plato's dialogue the Meno ends up coming
more or less full circle by the end of
the dialogue because it starts out with
this guy Meena who's not an Athenian
he's visiting and he says to Socrates
convert you be taught and Socrates says
hey whoa whoa hold on there buddy I'm
not even sure what virtue is so you're
asking me whether something has a
particular property I don't know what it
is yet and that's a problem we need to
inquire into that we're going to talk
about that in another core concept video
I do want to signal that Socrates
towards the end when when they you know
sort of give up the quest for figuring
out what actually is virtue he tells me
no because Meno still wants anokhin
virtue be taught he says we don't know
what it is but I'll go along with you
that's the thing about this in terms of
something like a hypothesis you know and
again it's sort of like mathematics
mathematics doesn't necessarily have to
be the case when they make a hypothesis
but if it were the case then these
things would follow from that and we at
least know that amount we know that much
right
know what would be hypothetically the
case so Socrates says well
hypothetically speaking let's say that
we actually do have some idea about what
virtue is and actually he probably does
have some idea because we see this
coming up in other dialogues and it does
get me know to acknowledge virtue is
going to be something advantageous so he
doesn't know at least certain properties
of it he suggests that it might be
wisdom or at least be guided by wisdom
there's there's a lot of things going on
here put all that aside and Socrates
says we still don't know what virtue is
but let's say that it is a can knowledge
or a kind of wisdom what can we say
about knowledge there's there's some
people who actually teach it now you
might say wait a second didn't he just
in the doctrine of recollection tell us
that there aren't really any teachers
there's just reminders and some
reminders are better and you know
learning isn't really being taught it's
it's remembering what we learned in a
previous life all that kind of goes by
the wayside is he's talking about he's
going back to a more more you know
typical conception of what counts is
teaching and learning and he says to me
know there should be some teachers if
it's knowledge somebody actually ought
to be able to get other people to be
better off with respect to virtue right
they come in one side of the virtue
Academy they go out the other side and
they actually understand virtue or they
have practiced it to some degree or
they're on the way or at least they have
the textbook right so Meno goes along
with this and then the question is if it
can be taught if it is a kind of
knowledge then there should be teachers
are there any teachers who are these
people and so they go through this this
discussion and now another person comes
in Anytus who is a young man of athens
by the way is one of the people who's
going to prosecute Socrates
in the trial that leads to Socrates
death and Socrates you know he wants to
suggest a couple different people Anytus
comes up with a few people as well but
they start with the Sophists and the
sophist were sort of like wandering
intellectual guns for hire and and most
of them were not from Athens they came
from other places and they you know
there was a whole variety of them many
of them we don't know that much about
except by you know attestations here and
there quite a few of them actually wrote
things that have been lost antiquity
some of them claim to only teach
rhetoric or the art of speaking well
others made claims to have knowledge
about all different sorts of topics
the very word sophist comes from Sophos
which means wise so they were claiming
to be able to impart wisdom to people
and Athenians would would hire these
guys for a couple different reasons one
was Athens was a democracy and in a
democracy to protect your own interests
you needed to be able to speak in the in
the public arena you had to be able to
make your own case and so if somebody
could teach you how to speak well that
puts you in an advantage and if other
people could speak well then you
couldn't have put you in a disadvantage
the other thing was a lot of Athenian
you know middle to upper class citizens
wanted a good education for their
children and there were already
traditional established ways of studying
various arts various techniques you know
for example they can be taught how to
ride how to throw the javelin how to
wrestle you know you suddent you send
your kid to the wrestling instructor if
you wanted them to learn an instrument
they can learn an instrumental though it
was primarily a servile occupation and
the Sophists were claiming to provide
tutelage in all sorts of different
subjects not just about how to speak
well but how to think
so they're a good candidate for who
could be the teachers of virtue some of
them did claim to be able to teach
virtue Meno says that gorgeous actually
says he can't teach virtue or he's not
going to teach virtue only that people
teach people how to speak well but other
Sophists claim to be able to teach it
and the discussion here is not not as
deep as it could be a notice immediately
says those guys know there's no way I
would let my kids anywhere near them and
we ought actually drive them all out of
the city
and so actually says well you've got
some really strong opinions on that you
must know these guys really well and
aniseh the Anytus says I don't go
anywhere near them and so Socrates just
sort of lets that slide the idea is that
Anytus doesn't actually know enough
about these guys what it is that they
promise what it is that they can deliver
on to people to have any sort of liable
judgment about this but Socrates you
know asks me no but what about gorgeous
and gorgeous sort of takes himself out
of contention by saying hey I don't I
don't even try to teach her at you all I
do is teach you how to speak well and so
that would disqualify them as well and
the other question that you can ask them
will get to is whether their teaching
has any good effects Anytus proposes
ordinary citizens you want somebody to
be virtuous just have them live with and
you know spend time with as we would say
in today's you know business world
shadow right if you're an intern you
shadow the successful person and you get
to see how they behave and how they
approach problems and who they interact
with who they avoid and the kinds of
interactions that they have and what
they play in and what they what they
leave up to chance and gradually you
sort of you make their their mode of
living or mode of choosing their mode of
thinking your own you appropriate it
right and it just has the the sense that
that's how virtue gets taught just going
to be brought up in the right kind of
household and you know there is
something
to this idea aristotle will actually
later on say you can teach virtue it's
also really important to have the proper
upbringing that that helps out a lot
Socrates turns the discussion away from
just plain old ordinary citizens and to
what we might call exemplary citizens
statesmen those who are involved in
exercising power in Athens in major
decision-making in public deliberation
about not only what's just and unjust
like in a trial but also about what's
what's useful or expedient or profitable
and what is harmful or in expedient sort
of things that we call public policy
right and he says there have been some
some outstanding individuals now the
question that we want to ask is whether
they were actually able to teach anybody
else how to be like that and so we asked
do any of these the sophist the ordinary
citizens the statesmen do any of them
reliably make their students or you know
their children virtuous people he
Socrates actually in this case of the
Statesman brings up examples of people
who did provide their children with a
great education but seem to have left
out the most important part how to be a
decent human being how to understand and
aim for and achieve excellence
that's what virtues have been so when
asked about this Anytus and Meno can't
produce any examples of anybody who has
been benefited in any way by any of
these people so that means that none of
them are actually able to teach virtue
they may some of them have virtue but
they're certainly not able to teach it
now that's a big problem because
if they did really know it according to
Socrates they ought to be able to impart
that knowledge to another person maybe
not everybody but at least at one person
at least the people that they're closest
to have least the people that they have
the greatest interest in becoming
virtuous in the case of the sophist the
people who are paying them money in the
case of the Statesman their own children
who they would want to you know live a
good life and you know set good examples
of their own what it really comes down
to is that none of these people can
actually provide an account of what
virtue is any more than Meno and
Socrates are able to in this dialogue
and if you can't provide some sort of
account if you can't at least tell
yourself here's what I'm actually doing
if you can't you know bullet pointed or
diagram it at least or come up with some
way of making sense of it that actually
holds water how are you going to teach
it to another person just by saying
we'll just do what I do that doesn't
work because because all these people
can do that it doesn't produce virtuous
students virtuous protegees virtuous
fellow citizens so the conclusion is
none of these people actually teach
virtue because none of them actually
know what it is if any of them indeed
have virtue or something like virtue
it's because they they have been lucky
they've managed to arrive at a true
belief or true opinion rather than
actually having firm knowledge about
what it is that we're talking about here
so to answer the question in this
dialogue just this dialogue because if
we were going to ask it in the Republic
you know or perhaps even the symposium
we'd be talking about you know somewhat
different matters at least as far as
this dialogue goes the conclusion is no
we can't teach virtue